[Music]
what's going on you guys Lord at here
coming at you for go you can't hear me
we hear hear the intro
yeah playing on your background that was
that was very professional where like
cudan you know counted us down me I just
play copyrighted music the of my stream
I just let it roll for like a couple of
minutes oh know how this Show's going I
already know how this Show's going
what's going you guys welcome to another
adct show we talked about the past
present future G I got my co with me
dirt G what's going on Dirk no much man
I was just tripping because I forgot I
had the show plan in the background I'm
like why I hear everything twice so that
was on me what's up everybody a lot to
talk about man we got King Dave here
fanga here manell first time chopping up
with him man I'm glad to have you here
bro yeah you it's great it's because
like all all these XBox guys are very
nice you know they want to talk and play
games and every time like I want to talk
with the PlayStation guys they're like
we don't want you here go away I'm
like understand
understandable understand video about me
back in 2019 I mean it was funny it was
funny to me because I was like Phil SP
said we're gonna have games what I kept
on oh yeah the games are coming I said
it about 15 times in the video yes you
did see I the games are coming I
remember I remember that video I was a
few years early but I was
right because crazy is is is when fanga
made the inous back to back yeah that
was funny man
funny you I want some back history from
you what when you were editing that and
you did did you go back and like listen
to it again say that would like make a
cool little meme or like did you hear me
the first time you said it and knew
exactly how you were gonna play that
like well here's a story I had loaded up
my canister with three whippits and I
was just like all right
I was just
like you know my brain had Frozen that
night and in the middle of the process
of my brain freezing I had like I S I
heard you going back to back after I saw
like um what's his name broken games
broken games HD gets all sad he's like
oh my God I can't believe it and I'm
like and I just hear you in the back
behind him going back to back I'm just
like I'm gon roll that every time
there's disappointment because it just
works and
I had a lot of see in my head yeah in my
head when you did it it sounded like you
there was like there was like a a choir
of you saying it you know when
I so I was just I couldn't help it I was
like I saw a choir of you saying it so I
like yeah that's where the inspiration
came so yeah but again it was all you
addict I mean you're the one who pulled
it
off so yo uh we we we got we got a uh a
new guest new guest in here fanga what's
going on man me the new guest ah well
yeah I guess I've been I've been um I
haven't actually been on your guys' show
this is my first time yeah but uh it's
it's an honor to be here it's an honor
to be here uh every everybody that I
know in this group here is really really
cool people real Gamers people who
actually do play their video games when
I get a
chance I'm sure Cog is is gonna watch
back this and be like okay can fenta
keep it civil before I get him on I am
pretty civil right now you see all I did
I only took I only took five gummies
we're
good
said each of those is 100 milligrams
don't you wa so so so are they shroom
gummies or they just uh THC gummies just
regular THC ones like my uh I'm not I'm
not going to take the shroom gummies as
a as a first first time
appearance that's not going to go well
a couple a couple of times I'm rocking
in the corner during a stream and the
audience is just like making fun of me
I'm just like
y have a great time you know what's
funny when you when I see uh you know
your your like logo and backdrops and
your videos I'm like why do I really see
him doing exactly this in real life
right now W and I think that was like
your goal your goal was to like like
give a like a funny vibe why why you
like roast people well my whole goal was
my whole goal was to be like okay how
far can I take it as a faceless YouTuber
because I mean if you want to make it
big on on this platform you got to have
a face out there everybody know that
like the biggest you done a very good
job though I do think that was the the
thought process in the beginning let's
keep it a buck in the beginning it was
avatars and little heartbeats going off
like that I pretty much paved the way
for changing that bull uh I ain't like
that I was like I can't King told us put
your camera on damn it yeah for real
know I said I'm not coming on your show
unless your face is
out camera on man you know I i' I've
made a good I've made I've made an
exception like well people make an
exception when it comes to me luckily uh
because most people there are people who
are like I don't really want to bring
you on unless you have a webcam Yeah in
our community yeah like there wasn't a
lot of like face cams but like believe
it or not King like actual YouTube
that's a
standard yeah well back then people
didn't want their real life tied to to
you know their YouTube account that much
but nowadays it's like people know when
you were born where you live how much
you make who you [__] last night they
know all that [__] like they just
[__] know it and so you're just like
you know what I don't want to keep my
face off than
that but no I I I mainly just really
like my privacy and it's like one of
those things is like if you ever need to
just walk away from YouTube you can
literally walk away you know um I like I
like it when people notice me outside
and and and and I like I like I like a
lot of the ponies to understand
like on God and them I smack the crap
out of you for real like so I want you I
want you to don't I want to put a face
to it so that's why I tell those dudes
man have a face to it so I know exactly
CU a lot of times people say something
that they will never say in your face
all the time oh D I get that all the
time I get that all the time yeah got
some bold dudes you got some bold dudes
and that's cool if you're gonna stand on
your Square do that but understand there
consequences and
repercussions it it it took me a long
time to not take it like take those
people personal like it took a long time
it took me a lot of practice because I I
used to be unhinged myself but uh
because you know these MOS will approach
you nowaday and they'll just be like he
used to be
unhinged yo I said the other day it's
only three people that I religiously
watch three people it's uh
Alex mixing and you whoa you watch mxy H
the reason why is all three of you bring
something that I can't do right one you
your editing skills oh
yeah God tear God te right uh Alex the
way that he will find whatever you said
on Twitter and throw that on the big
screen I actually I actually feel like
fantango the way you do your editing is
better than Alex because Alex can rely
on his his face cam for a lot of the
shots right he just edits around it like
you have to literally entertain people
without a figure on the screen and keep
them entertained for sometimes 15 to 20
minutes at a time and that's the
difference right there and then Mixie
y'all all can talk in a way that I can't
talk right because y'all can curse and
y'all can get to the to the angle how I
can't get to it and that's what I love
let's say there's like 30 seconds Alex
needs to figure out to put the like you
know what it's time for a thigh slap
like PGA can't do that no no I can't do
that I can't do that but I'll tell you
what I can do I I can take all sorts of
substances for you on alive you know
I will you know people will sometimes
like you know I get I get paid to just
you know get high it's the greatest you
the greatest job I ever had really I'm
not gonna lie gentlemen it's it's been
an honor to be able to get paid to do
this I love your Spiderman take the fact
that yo you took that one scene that I
hated when he was fighting Mary Jane
yeah and you found the the chick that
she's supposed to look like you narrowed
down yo that video was my Bible and I
was really which one the one where you
put her face up and was like you can't
tell me that she didn't uh get herself
into this damn game and then when when
when uh Mary Jane was belittling
Spider-Man he was like what's up with
this you know feminazi stuff and yeah I
I loved it I loved it all I I I
appreciate that I've had people who like
the really like the game you know uh
come up and and tell me you know like I
agree with all your criticism I like the
game but I agree with your criticism
like okay yeah for real yeah like I'm
like I wonder if you you guys will be
able to handle it when I do it to
Starfield they'll be like no no no n go
get it I don't care I didn't I didn't
make Starfield I play Starfield how how
I like to play Starfield so people can
say whatever they want I don't care I
played so much Starfield that I just I
had to put it on a shelf that's so tall
that I can't reach it anymore cuz it it
was it was getting to the point where as
long as it was installed I would go to
play something else and then like five
minutes goes by and I'm on starf I was
like no let's let's get rid of this this
we're going to put this in the back you
we gonna put it on the top the the
tallest shelf on top the Shelf because
I'm tall I can reach the tallest shelf
but I can't reach on top the tallest
shelf uh so you know that that's how
I've avoided playing starfi you were
that you were that hooked to it huh yeah
with all the updates and stuff I I am
intrigued to go back and try it
out got to finish it bro I said ain't
finished it yet me neither yeah I
finished got hours in but I haven't
finished I saw I saw a crazy clip
someone posted on Twitter today where
like uh I don't know if you guys care
about spoilers though actually so I I I
kind of I'll I'll take my
headset so like it was H yeah no in it
when you go through the unity you go
through a different dimension and
someone's second playthrough the entire
like uh cast of characters were all kids
there's a scenario where you go on and
everyone's you yeah it gets wild it gets
wild but it's like I just don't want to
run a new a new game plus all I played
it a little bit and I acknowledge that
that was a cool little feature but it
takes too long to get there it's like
you have to play the game again it's not
enough to get me into the game itself so
fair okay all right King can put his
headset back on we done I I purposely
did not finish fin it because I play it
twice a week and I put in a couple of
hours and I do monotonous crap my my my
joint is stealing people ships that's
myob it's kind of fun to do it is fun to
do that in the game I got 13 of
them I was the biggest like ship
Terrorizer like in the Galaxy man it was
ridiculous yeah CU you made a whole
Juggernaut though they they they keep
track of all your stats I think I I blew
up like 10,000 ships like the whole game
I got I got good at the dog fighting I
got good at the dog fighting I got good
at it what is your strategy fanga so my
strategy is you want the thrusters
unlock the thrusters you don't got the
thrusters you're screwed out in space
because the thrusters allow you to make
sudden and sharp like turns like precise
turns what I do is most of the time the
fleet will be coming at you and they'll
all hit you at once it be can they can
be a [__] because they can wipe you out
like that um if they're all firing at
you so what I do is I go towards them
and then I turn around and I'm able to
basically be right behind them lock on
because you can actually lock on and
Target which systems you want to attack
yeah uh and then just do that spam that
uh upgrade to autoc cannons honestly
like I had to really invest in getting
good at the dog fighting because the
Crimson Fleet um factions quest line it
it reaches a point where you're just
like I am getting I am getting [__]
out here I was I got so strong my ship
that I can go to the Crimson Fleet uh
like space area and fight all of them in
that
area what I do is I I had like a big
giant tank ship pretty much and a bunch
of targeting targeting guns on it they
there was a quite a bit like it got to
the point where I had to like switch
things up because I was shooting so many
things and blowing up so many ships
there'd be certain ships I need to focus
on that ship and that ship only and my
my ship is like no we're shooting
everything El but what you need shot I
got I got to build something like that
sorry go ahead what no what I'll do is I
don't use my thrusters at all I stop and
I just sit right there and just shoot
them and that's it and they die and I
was just like because before I'm like
I'm following them I'm I'm trying to do
that last star fight of crap and it just
wasn't working and I'm like Dam dying so
I said you know what I'm just gonna stop
and I stood right there and I killed
everybody and I was like this works I
said this really works and that's how I
was steing ships I I I I you know at
times we I had fun with the space combat
only when I had all the skills and
points for it without it it's not fun
without it I could see I could see why
reviewers uh and some like players IGN
dudes
no screw IGN I don't give a [__] now
they did something good today IGN is on
their job shout
out shout out to Rebecca Valentine you
did your job
you mean to tell me you guys mean to
tell me the tax was lifted for a Day N
they put the tax they put the tax on um
the messiah's
back the though right that's going hard
yeah it was like man your DNA is Xbox
you going to get this
work that's what it was that's what it
are you say where he where does he
come that's where the the king just
pulls it out of his head are are you
saying that Bungie had too much Xbox in
him so that got hit by that's exactly
what it was cuz you ain't see it look
you look at it how it goes down right
they said no Bungie knew exactly what
they was getting into Sony ain't doing
nothing wrong what you literally have
people over there talking about they
suck the sto out of us
PA King I saw the craziest stuff man I'm
like what and they blame bu they blame
they're 100% blaming Bungie they saying
all bung fult like wow what is it Jim
Ryan said he he felt he could get a
bigger investment out of Bungie than the
Activision Blizzard oh did what he
said you know what's funny you know
what's crazy though is this is what's uh
[__] up about Sony is that they've set
Bungie up to fail so they can sweep them
up yes and that's just dirty yeah I mean
like Microsoft ain't like trying to
triple like Activision Blizzard and be
like you're ours now right you know but
they walked in with the the pink slips
already they don't they don't have a
peak slip down the
line down the line hold the
slip hold the
slip I could just see one of those one
of those sliding doors and budy trying
to get out and you just see Sony running
at them with a s hold that
man yo it's the problem is is when they
gave him the contract Bungie think
they're always the smartest person in
the
room not knowing that they dealing with
a 25 year plusy old snake that has been
doing it to every person that they
purchase when they purchase um what
what's what's the what's the what's the
um sosis no not sosis they they
destroyed sosis if if anybody was
watching what they did to diagnosis that
was classic but what what they did to
the the dudes that made um that shooter
that that Rog likee shooter
um they have they have a French name uh
Rog like
shooter for the PlayStation 5 remember
the space shooter you die and she
reoccurs etal okay so house Mark
remember what they did to house Mark
house Mark was talking crap talking
about n it's not our game it's the
PlayStation 5 it's unstable and can't
hold it and it you keep shutting down so
the week yeah yeah the week later they
purchased system now shut up and sit in
the corner and don't ever say that again
and they never said it again now where's
the game that's coming from them because
they had a game that was in the
works are they a support studio
now they kill off the studios little by
little pluck the talent and leave them
as a shell they did it to Savage they
turned them into neon Abyss whatever the
hell that game yes yeah that's mobile
Studio yes keep watching the the
videotape I'm telling you they do it to
everybody look what they did to Naughty
Dog well they turned naughty dog into uh
into the last of us uh machine that's
all it focuses on now it's Dirty Work
The Last of Us The Last of Us for the
last three years it's just been The Last
of Us content nobody asked for that's
crazy man it is it is wild because what
people asked for was factions and that
was just on ice like no updates no we
don't know what's going to happen
apparently Bungie Bungie had influence
on that now we're hearing bungees and TR
I don't know what's going on at
PlayStation like like the only good
thing that about PlayStation was like I
Final Fantasy 16 this year I guess was
like one that's not
them true you're
right you're right according to the
PlayStation dudes they're 100% fine
because they sell well because the
console sells Nothing Else Matters it's
only console sales that's all that
matters according to PlayStation Fanboys
they're doing stream you well because
they sell consoles
they're if you're a car salesman and
nobody purchases their insurance are you
really selling cars or what the hell are
you doing CU ain't nobody turning them
things on those things ain't turned on
where the hell are
they facts that's true that's true
that's true great ack knowled you man
but that's what's going
on the the the tweets I've seen today
I'm like what happen to supporting the
DS the hell with hell with the
DS Wild yeah needs to take him over
because they're a mess over I'm like oh
my
God man it's uh it's I I I don't know
what the what I think a lot of it has to
do with uh Playstation like lacking a
road let's let's back up a little bit I
let you guys uh go crazy let's back up a
little
that is one of the topics so you know we
we will get to that here in a second uh
you know F first thing um you know King
what's going on man you know uh fga took
like the longest intro ever yeah
my's intro right there yeah right for
sure Xbox front line is what's going on
y'all gonna get that work this this
evening but I had to uh to jump on
because I I definitely love everything
fanga does and um I'm you know me and
adct is a buddy cop movie so uh I much I
very much appreciate it that you guys
enjoy the content it means a lot from
from from you guys especially you uh
King that means a lot coming from you
cuz you're you're [__]
hilarious let me tell y'all a story
about fanga real quick on my little
intro um he put up the hold the line
joint and somebody had tagged me and it
was like yo yo fena put up Hold the Line
in his in his chat or whatever so I hit
him up and I forgot what I said it was
just something mundane or whatever um
and he was like yo uh don't worry I'm
I'mma compensate you whatever I made for
that day for whatever my members or
whatever I'll compensate you and did
it you know how many people in this
industry steal stuff or or take stuff
from other people and don't say nothing
do you know how many people got hold the
line whatever they merch store or
whatever and don't say nothing that you
know um and I go to everybody show watch
everybody's show just to put a like
share it out or whatever just to give
you a view sometimes I leave it on when
I'm doing something in a house because
everybody needs help and he is the only
one that said here you go am I really
the only one that paid you for that yes
that's nuts you should go I will go get
your money man no no no no no no it's
not that is that when now it was the
respect thing right that that's the part
about it it's it's about who's a standup
person and who really needs help who I'm
going to be there
for and so when you was on today because
when you was on last week I was like yo
I'm gonna be on then add light went out
or whatever but whatever it is I'm G to
support that individual because I
understand who stand up and who's not
wow I I just I can't believe what to
hear that that's crazy man that's see
why
I've had people use you know art pieces
that I commissioned to pay right but
keep in mind this is my fault all right
I'll take the blame on this one and
that's that the artist would commission
the art for me right because and I want
and I wanted to feature that for the
first time on the channel you know like
I paid so that I could yeah you know get
this art and have it featured as on
thumbnail or in the video of some sort
and I want to share it on Twitter and
then somebody takes it and already puts
it up for their thumbnail yep and I'm
just like okay that was on you because
you know you put that up on Twitter you
didn't say anything but it it should be
some professional
courtesy I messaged that guy and uh and
we handled it we handled it cordially
you know very well right and uh and and
so it's like uh but I didn't I didn't
ask I didn't ask for anything from him
because he's he's small really small
channel so I was like whatever but I I I
was just like you know I was just like
man I really wanted to be the first to
Showcase that art piece you know that
that's really what it was I didn't care
people used it I just wanted to be the
first to use it you know because I paid
for it but it was what it was and that
sucks but also I I I gotta keep it in
perspective right Xbox people were down
at this point in time and you know even
Ben he you know he reached out with
these coins and he asked me could he put
the whole the line on the coins and I
was like okay cool but just make sure
that you give it to some of the people
that I want you to give it to
right because it's certain people that I
mess with that's in the community that I
really mess with and just make sure that
they get one you know because this is
this is not just my thing when you when
you are creative and you make something
in a creative space it is given out to
the world and the world will use it how
they want to use it but at the same time
you're part of a movement and everybody
needed to feel a little bit something
because at that point everybody was at
their lowest especially if you was an
Xbox dude you was at your lowest at that
point in time so that that that part was
I was watching individuals That was
supposed to be standup dudes doubting
yeah without faith what you have yeah
right that one you know what's crazy the
crazy thing about King uh is I was on
Twitter and I was browsing and there's
these dudes that're just you know conso
Waring I forgot what day it was they're
just console Waring doing the same
[__] and I see King David posting
job
listings I'm like what a g so TI I like
what are they what is you know like Good
Old Uncle David looking out for everyone
I see homeless people every day I deal
with I see them I I give out clothes I
don't I don't throw anything away um I
whatever whatever I can do and what
people don't understand is yes Twitter
is nice but then when you're in the real
world I don't know who's on Twitter that
just lost their job right then and might
need a job and if I have a listen that
can help you out if I got something I
can help anybody at any point in time I
don't care because right now we're going
through some wild stuff and Men is being
targeted more than anything at this Mo
at this moment I want to make sure that
everybody is secure and good because we
we supposed to look out for one another
and we turn into some bitter backbite
and Weirdos and and I just don't like it
so sometimes you see me post something
that's uplifting you see me post
something that if you was 20 years ago
what would you say to yourself then you
know to change your circumstances just
little thought-provoking things to get
their running to get them going so
that's all I
do
sorry back to the topics you know sorry
ad sorry that was really that was really
nice that was really
nice so appreciate for coming through
you know I was gonna ask what everyone's
playing but uh you wasted enough of my
time so we're gonna move
on so first thing we're gonna move on to
is the first topic is Xbox at the VGA uh
you know we have been seeing a lot that
Xbox is going to be here there's been a
lot of rumors going on um I don't I know
people in the chat are going to say adct
but you're spreading the most rumors
yeah yes uh I feel you I feel you uh but
here's the thing it's coming out
tomorrow yeah you could wait you could
wait and and what I will say is you're
not gonna be disappointed my
dudes you keep saying that I keep I keep
seeing you say that on Twitter I'm like
what does he know that I don't know no a
lot you know I I I I doubted the king
once I won't do it again I won't do it
again it's it's certain stuff that he
knows it's certain stuff that I know and
he has his own sources I got my own
sources I want to see if they're right
because if they do this right now I
might as well just stick a nail inside
Sony and just let them be done you know
yo what is yo you can tell me after the
show yeah okay
cool you know what what you guys should
have told me before the
show but yeah so uh you know I'm going
tell you guys that you know guys are
going to be really really satisfied let
me get these super chats real quick $5
Super Chat for uh uh q q cucumber uh
strap in the chat it's going to be one
hell of a it's going to be a hell of a
ride uh you know every welcome Power
Boss to the to the realm welcome Power
Boss to the realm and we got a five oh
$5 super from Boston Ray that that
that's Tyler by the way King Boston King
Xbox runs things like Disney runs Marvel
or uh or Sony runs Spider-Man movie you
know that Mickey Mouse meme from South
Park where he's like what South Park do
I own
that I'm laughing at you Tyler because
you know something Tyler I found that
you's an undercover Sony lover
oh adct is a Sony lover look he's got
his PlayStation behind him you know he
doesn't have on screen his
Xbox he got Spiderman post you got star
for post in the background that's theer
the middle he turns it on yeah he turns
that on to keep himself war look no Xbox
in sight but he calls himself an Xbox
guy look at this insane yeah until they
get Final Fantasy soon as he get final
fanty I'm my hands
up put some marshmallows over there
marshmallows that's right you know uh
first off let's go around uh King what
what what do you want to see from uh
Xbox at the Video Game Awards and what
do you want to see just like in general
announcements at the Video Game Awards
pure domination
[Laughter]
I want I want to see Pony Tears like do
there's been so much of it this year but
if we conclude the year like this with
them it's oh it's been a rough year for
him hasn't it it's been a rough year
okay so this is this is exactly what I
want to happen it's been a rough
generation what do you talk I want B I
want Boulders gate to win game of the
year I want as soon as when Phil to come
out and announce that it's in Game Pass
day and date is gonna drop shadow drop
right now boom go get that right now and
while you at it I want y'all to welcome
larryan Studios to the Xbox home and I
you thank you for giving us game of the
year and I want him to I want him to
Mush Jeff keigley as he walk off the
stage you actually when I was uh when we
was doing IOP I said it would be funny
if uh Lorraine Studios don't accept the
reward Phil Spencer comes on the stage
and they're like it feels like thank you
I guess you guys are wondering why I'm
getting this reward because I bought
him be fine it's like I couldn't get in
this building without buying someone so
you need to understand if you get a game
of the year I'mma buy it it's funny it's
funny like you cannot literally buy
everything my I just bought Game of the
Year
[__] bought game of the you said money
can't buy everything what do I have in
my hand he's like money can't bu
everything he's like you know who said
that broke
people no so listen like I from from
Microsoft um I I don't I don't I don't
think Microsoft's
gonna not to my knowledge you say expect
something I'm expecting nothing what
should I expect from Microsoft at the uh
that you keep hinting at what should I
be expecting because I would like to
know give me a hint that was pretty good
that was pretty good so so d d man what
what what what what do you want to see
from the industry and from Xbox
specifically at this event with the
industry yeah whatever um whatever
happens happens but as far as from Xbox
I want to see a hail Blade 2
a new hellblade trailer because you know
hell Blade's been there 2019 the reveal
2021 the gameplay slice I want to see a
combat game play and a release day
because I'm still thinking it's first
quarter 2024 like I I'm thinking March
for some reason March 2024 just a
prediction and I've seen some stuff
about arcane's going to be there give me
that deign of three give me that deign
of three that's what I want after after
redf you want want them to work on
something again well this is Arcane Leon
because arane Austin I'm sure they're
during something well so so Leon I think
they're gonna show like death I think
they're gonna show dishonor three but
it's going to be mixed with the um with
the death people I think because the the
developer already said that they're in
the same universe so I expect dishonor
three from them so like death Loop and
dis is in the same universe yes yep hm
so you mean my man coob hey sucker Who
Am you it's kind of crazy that they're
in the same universe even though death
Loop looks like it just has like less
texture it looks like a blockier game
it's because death Loop's technically
like like kind of been like a a loop
over and over again like I enjoy death
flop to me it took me a couple hours to
get into it but I enjoyed it and
finished it to me what during the time
that everything's going on and
Dishonored I would say that is when uh
Colt's been stuck in that in that uh
simulation over and over again Co
Eastwood no you know what no now that
you guys mentioned Colt Eastwood
something just I just thought of it I
think I know what we may see from Xbox
if they show anything at this award show
I think it's gonna be that you know it's
gonna be a gears game is what I'm
thinking we're gonna see gears uh I
honestly think they're gonna give us
sneak peek to a new gears
game now now that I think about it
that's like the most like uh
logical logical one I could think of
like so you're keeping your expectations
in check I I get
that man you you guys are out here with
all the info teas yo they just announced
Wu Tang bro yeah man yo I can't wait for
that man yo and you know my intro King I
got that wuang play boy listen I'm a
huge fan I can't wait to see what that's
about hash just one
hey see hey yo forka I told you I was
three years early but Xbox got the games
are coming my brother all right all
right all right three years
later I can hear that voice in dirt's
head
[Laughter]
remember down the
video D like man for video I was me I
was at I only had about 800 so I like me
he did a video about
me like yeah I was like get out of here
it was fine to me I was like yeah I I
was that I did say that that many times
when you when you when you pointed out
how many times you said I'm like oh that
video I think I think fanga made a video
about kid smoo once oh I did everybody
made a video on kid smoo kid smoo like
kid move does everything he does on
purpose he's a he's a [__] uh what is
it that they to call it when you sell
fake tickets oh
God SC those guys what are they called
when they sell fake tickets I forget
what do you call well that's a scammer
but in the front of the stadium selling
yeah that's the one that you get up
there you give him your ticket you like
get out of here with
that is just a no no kid move is just uh
SC he's selling people he's selling
people wolf tickets 30
he people on
wolfo he plays well into he plays better
well into his character but these days
he's getting too old and tired to do the
character he said you old and tired I
mean I'm like I'm like he's got he's got
that Dad energy now he doesn't have the
Xbox Fanboy energy no more it's died
down that green aura has di died down on
him you know
he Ora it's kind of like how Gohan
couldn't go into Super Saiyan again like
that's him right now he can't
man blue the funny thing is get him a
green funny thing is like the initial
vision of Dragon Ball Z was supposed to
be Gohan be the main
character they they changed things
drastically look when it comes to
me yeah I I I just want them to be
consistent uh I do want them to be very
vocal about
exclusivity if something's on that
screen I want that sucker to say Xbox
and PC at the end of it like I don't
want I want people to see it on the
screen I want PlayStation fans to see it
on the screen but does it matter if they
dead doesn't matter if they're dead like
this is the question I got like if
they're dead does it matter if it come
out on their doorstep don't matter right
they're dead they're dying by 2027 there
will be no Xbox you guys you guys yeah
your enti existence will be obsolete
all of you 2027 they're gone that means
the world
ended that's what I want I I want them
to be very vocal about you know what's
coming what's not um you know the the
the the coming the the couple things
that I heard of like one I've heard from
multiple
sources if that is there and it is
true I want them to be very vocal that
that [__] is a TI that [__] is an
exclusive I want them to be very vocal
this is ours it's not yours it's ours
right right I think they've been very
vocal on what's going to be exclusive
and what's not I just don't want
like
another what's a what's a good example
it's hard to find an example oh like
Indiana Jones when they first picked up
that they're like yo that's not yours
you know what I'm saying like and we had
to wait till the actual um we had to
wait the court to know that it was
thought it was it was a multiplat for
the assumed that right we just assumed
it was because it's Disney right well I
mean like they've made it very obvious
that you know playground games are going
to be exclusive Bethesda games are going
to be exclusive not all Activision games
that's like so when like they were I
think I think the reason that Indiana
Jones was different is because it kind
of started before the acquisition and it
was a Disney owned IP oh yeah you know
what in that case it could very well be
a contractual obligation yeah but no
they had to go to court and renegotiate
it yeah they said Microsoft said I don't
care what it said in the contract I got
enough money to say no no that's what
they did and no popey biscuits for you
but sorry no what I like the most is and
and I'm sorry guys I know y you're gonna
say I'm a I'm a fake Xbox dude what I
like the most is I love the games to be
released on
Playstation but I like it is to be
inside Game Pass for free no money down
like I love that part I love that they
got a pay for MLB to show and we don't I
love the fact that they had to pay for
death Loop and we didn't I love that so
listen have fun bye I want them like
they said they're gonna make y'all go
broke you gonna be so upset you gonna be
looking at your TV like I hate these
dudes they're getting it for free and I
gotta pay that's right and they're gonna
make you cross Street you gonna give up
your evil ways you gonna walk right
across the street you GNA get a s
pass I about you guys but I mean they
got they got Quantum over there so watch
out you better watch out they got
Quantum right you're right about that
damn forgot about that one [__] that's a
rough one right there we can't do like
oh [__]
oops me it's like I've made so many
videos about these type of
games it's just got to the point where
it's like like let's just let's just get
with it man let's just get with u but
you know I think uh I think we're going
to move on from there because we we got
this GTA
6 that's going on and you know it is
kind of crazy
like I okay don't get me wrong I knew
this was gonna happen because GTA's
always been a very famous
brand but part of me didn't realize how
much
this was gonna happen really yeah no no
not to this degree because it wasn't
like this for the for for the GTA 5 yeah
so like is though well see I think
because it's coming from all it's coming
from so many sides and I think that's
what's throwing me off I think it's
because yeah social media has just risen
so high since all this has happened that
I think we're seeing we're seeing what
social media can actually really do
when the right game is behind it uh let
me get these super chats real quick we
got a $5 Super Chat for the angry
therapist stopping by to show support
appreciate it my dude got a member chat
from Joey it's been a member for 16
months up Joey wbg member yeah we got we
343 looking mighty fine now H next that
is kind of crazy we're gonna get to that
here in a second then we got a $5 Super
Chat from Nintendo Dawn
theotaku did you already talk about Wu
Tang no we
haven't uh we will be talking about that
here momentarily after GTA 6 so first
off what I think it's probably already
surpassed like the lifetime views of GTA
did it did yeah in like4 hours one day
that's crazy and what did you guys think
when you saw that 2025 I think we all
kind of knew that 2027 for me
realistically oh oh like as a PC more
2027 for
Mees sad news such sad [__]
news I was thinking 2024 adct I just
thought it was gonna come out next year
because you know they're showing a
trailer this year I was
late rockar like showing multiple
trailers so what they'll do is they'll
show this trailer now and like three or
four months they'll show another trailer
and another three or four months to show
another trailer they love building up
this crazy hype and then like like the
last six months before the game comes
out they'll drop like a trailer every
two months like because remember right
now they haven't touched anything Story
related they haven't touched anything
and they have they have that that chick
narrating it like they did at GTA 5
showing you how the online features are
like like they have they they really
generate a lot of unique marketing
ployes like they're literally going to
Market they they're making they're
making money marketing their game which
is that's the whole thing here I mean
like and they're going to milk that I
would you know if like I made money just
promoting my game because it got so much
viewership I mean 100 million views in
24 hours well crazy what what they did
was they put the console manufacturers
on notice right so they're they know PC
shut up y'all gonna have to wait I know
what they did did with um Xbox and
Playstation was where's your pro
consoles at right now y'all can get into
the biding War for the marketing rights
we're gonna give you a whole year to get
it
together that's it I think Microsoft
should just bow out well or just sit
there and just keep raising it and keep
making Sony add more money like they did
to Bungie keep keep keep making them pay
more money to get the marketing rights
and in the end just let Sony get the
marketing rights but let them get the
marketing rights for like three billion
did youall see how how Twitter like the
the pony side of Twitter was on fire
about marketing rights for GTA 6 on
PlayStation or
something uh that what what was that all
about just I don't even know I guess
like the Mind said that it's impossible
for Xbox to get the the marketing rights
to the game like I feel them I
understand where they're coming from
look at the end of the day they're going
to go with the the people sell more it's
like that's not always necessarily the
case you know if Microsoft popped in
there and was like we'll pay for all the
marketing
okay the odds of them getting it I would
say is low but to say they can't get it
I feel is not a right statement yeah oh
we can't lie though like a bundled A PS5
GTA 5 bundled
PS5 like that would be a pretty good
selling that would be pretty that a lot
of people for like their holiday season
like but I don't see that happening for
like three years or so you know like a
PS5 bundle GTA
6 um I could totally see it
happening that's why I don't want uh
that's why I would I would really like
if Microsoft can get their hands on that
marketing because I do think it would be
very Microsoft needs to do a better job
of getting Xbox in front of casual
brands in GTA 6 I don't think there's a
bigger casual brand uh brand you can put
yourself aside like that that would
especially if they were able to bundle
it like officially bundle it that with
that holiday it it would fly off the
shelves fly off honestly like that the
potential to make a lot of money is here
like that bundle happens but uh wait a
second to on I I was getting up and I
heard y'all say that the pony said that
Microsoft can't get the marketing yeah
they were saying that they still so
arrogant bro arrogant for what y broke
like arrogant for what like y don't got
any money man like arrogant for what you
they just spent 70 billion you got a
dude that's in charge that said they're
gonna spend you out of business that's
one game that could put you under if you
don't think Matt booty ain't up inside
the room talking to everybody saying
this could kill him I think this can
kill him you know would be crazy if not
only Can Microsoft secure that marketing
because the marketing might not even
have been chosen yet like because that's
probably would be chosen later if if it
hasn't been chosen already it would be
kind of crazy if they do get the
marketing for GTA and they're marketing
GTA and Call of Duty in one year oh my
God uh that would definitely that would
definitely give him quite an edge hey
let me say real quick I thought add made
a great point the casuals right now like
we talk about the Casual all the time
the casuals chose the PS4 the casuals
chose the 360 casual chose the PS2 and
be honest they chose the PS5 so far the
generation if they can somehow like you
said adct get the casuals to notice the
damn uh Xbox because I'm G tell you like
the guy that does my beer right he's
like 22 years old young dude he thought
the Xbox series s was the only
Xbox that's that's bad marketing on Xbox
yeah when I told him I was like no man
they got one that that's even more
powerful than the PS5 he's like really
is the Xbox I was like yeah man he
didn't know you know I'm saying so the
casuals think that the PS5 is like the
only console to get they don't even look
at Xbox some of the casuals right so
marketing Call of Duty and like you said
adct marketing GTA GTA is the one game
like King said see there's a lot of
factors damn okay let me give me your
Xbox there's a lot of factors to owning
a platform and I think
Microsoft either back the wrong third
party marketing or they don't try to
like out bid for the right ones and and
what what I say about that is I don't
think it's a coincidence that every
generation almost the winner of the
generation went to whoever was marketing
Call of
Duty I think you got remember pretty
like the 360 Xbox marketed essentially
that whole generation and then the the
Xbox one generation they had like one
game in the Xbox one generation and then
PlayStation marketed the rest yeah but
see the thing is you got to also
remember the fact that Microsoft had to
make the pivot to Game Pass so now that
game pass is an established entity and
it has games and they have games that
they could put in it they can go back to
what they was doing before because all
they would do is get third party Deals
they would get marketing deals but they
didn't have anything in their own
coffers so they kept they they they was
biding against themselves now they have
a bunch of stuff that they can throw
inside their game pass now they can go
after uh third party deals in such a
visual way that it will force Sony to
either adapt or die and you seen Jim say
I'm going to adapt I'm gonna get 12
games of service but you did it with
weak Pockets right so you're doing it
with weak Pockets now the board looks
over at you like yo we dying over here
we gotta cut that down we got to get
back to what we know what we know best
but you Midstream you can't go back
Downstream this is the part where
they're vulnerable at and if Microsoft
can't
this Grand Theft Auto
marketing it's
over it's it's literally and I dudes out
there I know you PlayStation dudes out
there never we just throw out another
God of
War you so you say if PlayStation
doesn't get marketing it's over yeah
yeah play yeah yeah if they don't they
dead said no well if if okay so
Microsoft has to get marketing and in my
opinion if if if you want to really
finish Kong off finish Kong off if you
really want to stop his
heart you have because listen they could
say they got 40 million PlayStations out
there 40 million out there only 25 is
turned on I don't know where the rest of
them is that right but Warehouse King
hey I showed you those dudes I know them
right
so yo it it it it don't smell right like
they hey one of
those right now you got old W yeah okay
you guys all right so so lonar in the
chat says that it was leaked GTA 6 will
be bundled with the PS5 Pro is that true
was that no that's a pony joke
Pon you know Modern Warfare 2 the Modern
Warfare 3 bundle you know it's it's it's
bundle with Starfield too right shut up
all
right very interesting gamer by choice
brought up something very
interesting imagine he had $2 Super Chat
imagine Cod and GTA bundled selling
during that holiday that be big man and
Game
Pass if Microsoft was able to get the
marketing rights the GTA 6 and they were
willing to pay them the money to put to
bundle it with the the Xbox and on top
of that they put a Game Pass uh card in
there for Call of Duty that would
probably triple anyone's console CS that
that year add add I got something better
oh God oh God I got something better
okay hold up hold up hold up make make
Sony overpay for
marketing then then go right behind him
and get these dudes a bag to put it in
Game Pass and let Sony Market it and you
got Game Pass you kill them
all that's exactly how you do it I'm
down with that I'm honestly but like
realistically though I think they're
they're going to go with PlayStation
because they're naturally going to go
with who has the highest console user
base go generally it does work that way
unless Microsoft unless Microsoft's
willing to give them enough money to
offset the the install base they would
go to the highest install base
but and 2K have enough influence and
enough brand recognition where they
don't necessarily because most of the
time you go to the marketing with a
bigger install base because you want
your game to sell as much as possible
but I do think gr Grand Theft Auto 6 is
an exception it it's definitely not the
role it's an exception to that so I
think they have they could be a little
bit more Ling to instead of going for
the people that has the most install
base they go to the people that can give
them more money that part I think maybe
this is
part of the reason they got Activision
Blizzard was because of situations like
this where it's more than likely
PlayStation will have the marketing
deals for games like GTA 6 but uh you
know to combat that they have Activision
Blizzard for Call of
Duty they got a bid for those there
there's not many there's not many games
that can that marketing would be bigger
than Cod uh GTA 6 is definitely one of
them it's one of the ones GTA 6 is like
one is like one of the rare games that's
yeah there's very few you know I I would
say you know even hogwart's Legacy that
sold very well sold a lot of
PlayStations but I think there was a lot
of political stuff going on in there why
that sold so well you know I wouldn't
say it was entirely the game it was a
decent game people say people say it
goes to the highest bitter that's what
justing highest bidder not who has the
biggest the
pr we'll see we we'll see about that one
since Microsoft is taking their
marketing the prettiest girls don't go
with who got whatever they go with who
got the most
money a question though I'm just saying
though guys a question though who uh uh
so like GTA 5 was marketed by do we know
because I'm questioning I think it was
PlayStation it was PlayStation was it
okay because remember it was in the Xbox
360 generation PS3 generation Xbox got
San Andreas I think it was no no no no
no no PlayStation 2 PlayStation 2 got
San Andreas Andreas I think Xbox 360
marketed for because remember they had
some exclusive DLC on the Xbox yeah they
had the ballot of Gay Tony that one I
just feel that GTA 6 is going to be so
big do they even need someone to Market
their stuff I
mean regardless that part it's it's
about all it's about Microsoft and Sony
at this point GTA is gonna do what
they're gonna do right right so as a
girlfriend what is this yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah and she's pretty what what in
the world is going on said what is
this that scared
me
unb loves him look at this guy look at
this guy no wonder he's so happy and
confident yeah a man man that's exactly
how Xbox dude Xbox dude's got
girlfriends oh [__] look at that he's
touching he's touching touching lips
look at that yeah yeah go so proud of my
boy so proud PlayStation dudes got cats
oh shout out shout out to Christopher
hard I saw you got your new
cat like adct is loved by someone
what he got a new he got a new Homeless
Cat shout out to you picking up your
homeless caty man that's that's that's
great Chris you're adopting homeless
cats man hey shout out to you I've adopt
him he gonna be a homeless cat too once
that PlayStation
die I could just I see King right now I
could just see Chris sitting there he
you know he sees all the announcements
at the Video Game Awards he sees Call of
Duty marketing he sees that that those
sales pick up and then he just okay I
guess you know that Chris Chris watch
you know you know that hold up you know
that Meme where it show SpongeBob say I
guess I'mma head out it's I guess I'm a
head to the to the
Vex going he's going to the animal
shelter it's time to get a third cat hey
I guarantee whenever PlayStation is on
stage or something Chris heart watch it
like
this like his Fe
his swinging in the back with his door
open with his speed
up what's going to happen I guarante is
it another award does it have a jump
button I can see something getting
announced like he's
like oh we got land on the stomach they
got the last of they got The Last of Us
Part One with with with with this guy's
face now on it oh just a movie
adaption y y'all wrong man I can't
believe this hell yeah I'm wrong so what
what what else the
go Packers why don't you get the hell
out of here
punk punk ass out of here man tell what
Happ what he do he just come here
talking y' y'all trash Xbox trash games
shut up well well I don't know why you
read it because if it's not in color I
don't see
it games are low
quality King's model if you're gonna
talk [__] you better pay money and you
know what he he talking to himself let
him do it like don't throw him out let
him sit right there and watch us
no King he's not talking to himself he's
got cats oh oh yeah I forgot and you
better clean up that litter box you're
starting to smell funny I could just see
him right now King he's sitting he's
just petting the cat can you believe
what king just said about me he's like
you're such a great cat he's just he's
sitting there he's sitting there all
like alone sad and he's like look at
these guys having a good time [__]
them I hate them they're enjoying
themselves how dare they y he dirt he's
sitting there with his limp brush yeah
you
know how dare they disrespect Sony I
mean I mean come on I ha these
guys that one that one crowd that once
nothing but pure serious game talk I
can't be around those crowds oh hell no
I can't I'm like I'm like you I'm like
you're like just not a pleasant person
to be around if you're just like I need
you to talk about this
seriously okay what I what I need the
chat to do okay I I know there's some
mods in there I know they are yeah this
dude uh go Packers I want you to keep
that clown timed out okay no let
him freedom of speech freedom of spee
let him talk let him talk let him talk
talk his [__] hey Freedom don't I don't
see it freed understand the freedom of
speech thing it's a public platform but
I treat it like it's my house I don't
nobody take your shoes off when you
enter well see what you do is listen if
if okay if he's cursing yeah but if he's
just saying sbox sucks okay cool I'm
glad that you tune in I'm glad that you
watching I'm glad that you put a thumb
down the algorithm has counted you too
sir I appreciate
let the algorithm algorithm you going
stay there stay there and watch your
style on you baby and I want you to
still I want you to add me on Xbox
because I know you got a Xbox you bought
it when you got the cat hey hey how many
Y how many uh how many of these dudes on
Twitter that you see every day talk
about Xbox how many of them own Xboxes
I'm pretty sure like almost all of them
do all of them do they all own an Xbox
all of them do all of them got they all
hate buy Microsoft products which is the
[__] funnest part to me they hate
purchase things like I'm gonna buy this
to hate on it I'm like yo
fora that's not it what they what they
do is they know that it helps them s Ah
that's it hating on Xbox is popular so
their Channel blows up they in a crowd
with a bunch of guys that don't got a
girlfriend they got a bunch of cats they
all together with them
the Catman Catman Catman so they all in
together with this the Catman do so I I
like I love all you Thundercats so I
just want you closer to me stay close
watch us Style on you and when it's all
over when we killed Kong remember who
said he was dying I I will say I I will
say man I can't stand cman all right I
hope myom I hope my homie doesn't hear
this but I was over at my homie's pad
and we were blazing out and he's a cat
dude and he's got like three cats uhuh
and I'm just and I'm like I can't stay
in this house I'm like I got to get out
of here like it smells like cat piss cat
turn yes I was like the gray Aroma of my
good ass weed can't even cover this
stuff up I'm like I got to get the hell
out of here and if you if you fall
asleep they put their but holes in your
face P oh my
God I I'll stti I'll stick with my husky
I'm good I I'm good he might be he's
like he's he's better than a cat even
though he tries to act like one you know
so
it's oh well we we we go we gonna move
on to this uh sorry guys this W Tang man
first off let me get these super chats
real quick we got 700 let's get those
likes up how the hell we only got 21
likes and 700 on God them get your stuff
together who what is going on right here
this is this is
unforgivable this is unforgivable m is
in the chat by the way shout out to
good you probably have to refresh your
uh your browser oh hold on say 200
likes oh my my B makeing it seem like I
got a lot of haters no one liking it why
we only got 30 oh oh all right like this
stream we got we got two we got 200 yeah
we got back to back log into your
accounts back to back and like yo adct I
don't care a bunch of haters watching
let it watch tell them to like it back
to back because then they're unliking it
do it he said back to back unlike like
unlike like unlike like unlik let's
break it oh look at that getting free
kisses on stream look at him oh and
money he got money his woman gave money
and a kiss y you see you see the
difference you see what Xbox dude's
doing the world going on here this is
not Xbox dudes is doing a little bit
different I ain't never
seen anybody on the PlayStation stream
ever well King thrash is mean not
King the only thing PlayStation guys get
from their girl is a headache they don't
got girls what are you talking about
dolls don't
talk this is nuts this is absolutely
wild I can't believe it I'm betrayed my
whole life was a lie look at
this oh my God I was talking to and I
was they all date Annabelle dolls I got
to talk to I got to talk to Jess Gordon
also has he also has a woman I'm like
this is unbelievable yeah XBox XBox guys
do that what you talking about I'm like
this is this is insane I was like it
really is the PC crowd of that the neck
beard virgin losers yeah yeah listen I'm
telling you right now our wallets are
different know wallets are
different
to take our girls
out Xbox they got they got girlfriends
they got jobs PC people they might not
got girlfriends but they can edit like a
beast and
[__] portal they got a portal in the
cat portal in the cat they sitting they
sitting there letting their cat watch
cat movies and they sitting on their
portal don't forget your hey that's
that's why play Playstation got Strays
an
exclusive oh don't make
sense sense it makes sense ad you crazy
makes sense when you guys yo King when
you when I was rewatching your guys'
stream when I was editing that video a
few months back yeah when I was watching
his' stream and you're just like you're
like this is like the third cat game I
seen on this I I [__] fell out of my
chair I was like I was like that's kind
of go in the video that Place showcase
oh my God man it was you know what was
the best part about it when I had Jay
dubbed
there when we did the Xbox jump J J du
runs his mouth so much so seeing him
humbled was like Wow funny I I I set
that up got hled hard J because JB's
mindset is I'mma show up to this this
fire ass playst one and I'm a point at
King and then and then I'mma show back
up to the Xbox One and I'm a point at
King both times King pointed a
Jay and all and all I can say is he
abandon
you bro hey I know it's a few months old
now but I still can't believe how trash
that showcase abandoned
W abandoned as a I forgot that that game
doesn't exist Does it oh my God
likeo don't exist abandon do y'all
remember abandoned people was like look
look look my [__] abandoned is silent
hiliar is there certain someone that
likes drinking Jamba
Juice a few few people out there and and
then they would insult you if you didn't
see it y'all don't see it y'all don't
this is Silent Hill y'all don't see it
my
God
hey at least at least you didn't have
conspiracy theories made about you
because you had lunch at
breakfast Hotel because we in
Illuminati too
we're chck cont tenders don't look right
my [__] something a
right I never attenders like
that so you that's Rick
Ross I'm sitting there counting you know
there there's a cup right here
it's Aaron Greenberg don't have any
vegetables on his
plate nothing is not right Xbox conso is
not popular all right it's not what you
got what you got to say at the end of
that they sitting has too many cups
boss
boss you listen cuz I was there
obviously I was in the picture and when
you listen to the conspiracy theories
not just him but multiple people made
I'm just like how did you come to this
conclusion because it wasn't there they
don't go outside they don't know how
outside what
funny they were like yo you know there's
a person here they're not there so you
know what that means that means they're
they're taking a picture of someone with
Aaron Greenberg he they paid for this
I'm like Co Eastwood's wife took that
picture you
CL ridiculous man there some people
having lunch man like come on man and
people was like well why did Aaron
Greenberg take a picture it makes no
sense um he's the marketing manager you
you clown like I
say to
Mark [__] you doing in
Japan what's this [__] doing in Japan he
don't forget the other guy said well uh
you know these guys are being pushed uh
Dirk gri is being P the next one they
need the he said they need the next
[__] he's the next
one see k smoth k smoth was critical ofx
so they need another black to take so
that's why they push dir gri gy is the
next Blacky up me another black I was
like
what
f i so bad for for you know forget all
the hard work and all the grind you be
putting in be he someone came in the
back door and unlocked it said come on D
come on come on in
you move out because he critical come on
your turn we K we kic we kiic kid smoth
out the front door it
stuck said let's get a chocolate with a
beard let's get a chocolate let's get a
d baldheaded s him in bhead is in let's
get a l cage looking N word oh yeah we
in the Luke Cage
one black
baldheaded come on man what we're well
funded we paid for all that yeah
all all of them get a push did you guys
get your check for Microsoft this month
no mine come on the
25th what
you what are you going no actually it's
not the 25th King it'll be like the 28th
25th of holiday exactly that's the
holiday that they send it out they put
they putting the presents on the a by
tree hey get Christmas bonus get
Christmas
bonus they gave everybody P what
portal PlayStation portals Spencer no
Spencer's Gonna Leave a nice Corvette
under called te's tree it's going to be
like tired in a nice I see walk up I
want hey I want only fans gift card
that's what I want walking Co walking
downstairs and he's like why is there a
Corvette what what happened to my house
they just ran it through his house and
put it under
his surprise
Co say everybody get um all the fail
projects they get all the fail projects
over at Sony they get uh the PlayStation
VR2 for Christmas and they get the
PlayStation
portal hey hey did did did did you get
your uh unstable PlayStation 5 cuz I got
mine it's right here no no what I what
they did was they sent me the pregnant
undercarriage thing the thing that the
what's funny the funny story about this
PlayStation 5 here you know I had to
call my landlord be like yo the Heat's
out so he just he brought this over
instead oh wow very
clever said just turn that suck on about
30 minutes you might have to turn it off
he gave you he gave you a neck blanket
and and a PlayStation 5 yeah really like
my furnace isn't a furnace it's just
like eight or nine of these things in it
heat it up boy heat it
up oh God okay some of these to topics
before I go let me get these super chats
we got $2 Super Chat from Blue so corpse
bungee told factions what to do we'll
get to that here in a second we uh
two uh 279 Canadian Super Chat will GTA
6 be locked at 30 frames on the series s
and x uh most likely unfortunately five
from Dwayne Microsoft can spend $70
billion but make more than double that
back the next day spending Sony out of
business will be no issue fact we got we
got a $5 Super Chat from uh Raheem linor
I don't know PlayStation is on the phone
begging Rockstar right now we got a five
Super Chat who's seing the video of
PlayStation 5 theft does it count as
console sounds I did not see any games
some dude on Twitter some Twitter on
Twitter dud on Twitter was bragging
about it he's like he's like look how
popular PlayStation is everybody steals
it no one's stealing Xboxes and I'm just
like I'm like man this crazy did you see
the um did you see the the the video of
all those people like statch all the
PlayStation fives I bet you like
represent from PlayStation so be like yo
get some on the line that count to
sales yo they don't show you them
getting put in the Patty wagon right
outside the door we all know what
happens to the PlayStation they really
just show they're really just showing
the uh the employees not in their uh
their work uniform putting it on the
PlayStation
truck take them back all this stuff is
refurbished all they do is go around the
back and say sell these again that's all
what they're really going to do is just
sell them back yeah yeah oh my God okay
those Xboxes were too heavy so of course
they didn't want them
what got a $2 Super Chat from Karen's
raisin potato potato salad who y'all
fighting for the VGA viewing I'm unsure
currently we'll get back to you on that
is yeah Jonas the uh the dad frit D King
uh hell of a panel
well wild so wild $5 Super Chat from uh
uh JX 88 most Sony fans sit in the chair
with their cats like Dr claw refreshing
the newest IG article room straight
smile
straight
smelling what's up JF how you doing
brother
yeah respect Gadget right T
super is it gazley Sony realized Bungie
wasn't the Wu beef they order taking
them back to the alley where they bought
them excellent fi triple fake dudes
got I don't want this show to end $2
Super Chat from
uh Enigma dreams Xbox buy Square back uh
uh bring back parasite Parasite Eve yeah
e that's a dope last to play that game
back in the day all right what's the
last let see what's the last topic well
we are gonna talk about wuang do you
guys want to talk about that real quick
yeah real first let let's talk about
wuang uh it is okay first off I don't
know a whole lot about this I feel like
you know King and and dirt especially
will be able to talk talk about this
really good but uh explain to me what
the hell this is like I do have some of
the um it's music isn't it wooting the
group is that what you're talking about
or yeah yeah he don't he he didn't grow
up in that
no thought was like I was like I was
like I was like they're talking about
the group right yeah their music's
pretty good yeah so what what is this
because I have it right
here yeah what is you want to go first
well I mean I mean what you can read it
like read it Blow bit well for me um the
fact that wuang is being part of any
project the last time was Death Jam
Vendetta and fight for New York um and
then wuang also had a side project I
believe but wuang is woven into the
fabric of New York history right and the
group was a phenomenon that took over
the world uh you never had that many
artists that went solo that was that
good and together came back and formed
Devastator so the fact of the matter
that they still relevant to this day and
they're making a game that's going to
bring back their relevance even more and
their music has went on to become CH top
and platinum
hits uh wrapped inside this I know that
Microsoft has the pulse on the community
now and what they seeing is a gold mine
in in old music music that resonated
then that they can bring back now that
can transcend what the game is so a lot
of times when you see it's easier to go
get older music uh for lensy purposes
because they're dead and they're done
right there so you can add more value to
it and bring a game that's wrapped
around it I don't expect it to be a
triaa title I expect it to be a double a
title but like I was telling adct and
the team in the background is I expected
to drop inside Game Pass and for it to
resonate and if that happens then it
will be a Resurgence where you can get a
de Jam Vendetta you can get a streets uh
NBA streets basketball game I just about
to say that right so is these can happen
if the hip-hop culture can gravitate
towards this and it does sell and it
does uh resonate with the people it can
turn into something bigger than what
what we seeing right now I would
definitely play wuang uh wuang licensed
game I would definitely play that any
day yeah yeah I agree because they said
it's a it's a RPG like a co-op action
RPG right um I see I agree with King I
do believe it's going to be a double a
game a high quality double a game I hope
I'm wrong I hope it could be a AAA but
at the same
time great game you you say what like
high five Rush yeah oh exactly like or
like like RoboCop kind of like you know
I hey I finished that game I totally
enjoyed that game bro I I haven't tried
I haven't tried it yet but everybody
everyone keeps urging me to play it you
okay see back back when I used to
partake in the dev Devil's
letters I myself would take the devil's
letters and I would listen to Wang and I
would turn the sound off on the TV for
watch the news and the News would be
spitting the lyrics that's going on so
that the formative nature in my in my
youth is there so I'm gonna buy it
regardless 100% he's like he's like I
don't have to get high to remember being
high exactly that's that's true uh cuz
like you said I saw somebody put in the
um chat infrared gaming that they
recently had had that wuang TV show I
believe it's uh done now but that's show
I want to say I want to say something to
the chat member right here Power Boss
says fit's not like Alex frit doesn't
play as many games what do you I
actually be actually played and beat the
games they talked about this year okay I
was like what the [__] are you talking
about right goddamn come at me ever
again with like oh just plays gam Al I
don't play Path of Exile every single
day and nothing else
okay may have beaten all those like nice
little indie games you can beat in two
hours
congratulations okay but I actually like
to put a lot of time into bigger games
okay [__]
off me um so before you move you should
try travel for this one quick thing
godamn um I thought King Dave is
absolutely right about this wuang game
but look
wuang not just wuang like you mentioned
um Def Jam Vendetta de Jam fight for New
York those games are some games that
people still wonder are they ever going
to do another Death Jam fight for New
York game which was a game based like
the like full of rappers and full of
hip-hop the hip-hop culture so bringing
the wuang game I think will grab certain
people of course our gener well well me
and King generation I don't know I don't
know how old Fred is but uh grab me he
like out yeah I fig he's probably in his
30s or something but um and wuang was
huge man like meam man is a damn actor
now and he was one of the more popular
members of wuang Clan so having a XBox
exclusive game with wuang members
hopefully the game is good it's a
quality game man I think that game can
really bring attention to the Xbox
platform like yo man y got wuang gang
like a wuang clan game and I think
people like it man hopefully you know
it's a pretty good game so I'm excited
about it yeah I mean I mean I play I
played uh any of you ever play the uh
what was it the game by Jack Jack Black
he had like
um Legend yeah yeah Brutal Legend he has
one you
know highi Rush is another like musical
oriented game that I I really enjoyed
high five rush I would I and also like
jetset radio another game that I would
say like relied heavily on music
absolutely for RH abolutely I would say
a lot of these Rhythm games like I like
playing them so if they got if they pull
it off well with wuang if it's like got
some Rhythm based gameplay that goes
along with the RPG elements or whatever
this is going to be you know where it
requires you to listen time for attacks
and stuff like that it will be great
it'll be I'll play it I'll play it any
day because I'm a sucker for games like
that yep absolutely so let's go ahead
and rotate over here to uh our last
topic let me get this $5 Super Chat real
quick from Michael Mooney Microsoft has
130 billion cash reserves so they can
put GT in game pass along with take 2's
output for two years I feel you but the
problem is are they going to that's is
not going to do a Game Pass they don't
need to bro and welcome Jonas the dad to
a membership to the round Jonas the dad
the homie what's up man yeah welcome to
there okay so let's let's get into ah
Nintendo Don diaku with the $10 Super
Chat uh the three founders of the wuang
studio brass lion worked on De Jam
Vendetta Sleeping Dogs Mass Effect 3
combat
Skyrim Fallout 3 and Singularity and
just blaze okay yeah they have just
blaze as a music director yo that's a
nice resume right there that'll be good
that' be good so let's let's I'm G let
keing go first on here
right TTS King talk that yeah uh so
Bungie
recently just did like an an ominous
like reporting with IGN and it's looking
like there's a you know a good
possibility that maybe next year or I
don't know what the kind of time frame
is and how many like pay periods they
have to miss but if they miss a certain
amount it's looking like the deal that
they have with with Bungie Sony has with
Bungie they could just void all that and
say yo so is
M so you know I'm kind of curious what
you think on this King because me and
you were kind of against the cell from
the start because we kind of felt like
Sony would somehow because remember I
said I'm I I just feel like they're GNA
find loopholes remember well it's not
really a loophole they literally like
agreed to it but uh you know they signed
this deal supposedly after a certain
amount of time of missing expectations
we don't know if it's like one or two or
x amount but you know right now there's
a panel of of two Sony two uh Bungie and
there's one I think the CEO is is the
tiebreaker so y technically Bungie has
more power when it comes to voting for
thinks but if they miss expectations in
terms of financials I don't know how
many times Sony has the right from
Legally to just say yo this voting
process is trash where just taking over
yep so what do you think about that King
because I'm very
curious all right so after watching um
reading everything and I read it a
couple of times and I I sat back and
said damn man it's messed up
because the person that thought they was
the smartest person in the room that
they can finesse the great
finessa it ain't working like you was
the gingerbread man for a long time like
you you you finessed Microsoft you went
over there to Activision finesse
Activision and you thought Sony was
desperate and you didn't know what type
of individual you was dealing with like
this is you was playing around with a
serial killer thinking you can outsmart
him and it didn't happen little by
little what they did was they set traps
with your own ego right so they said
listen if you can hit these Milestones
then everything is cool and you like I
could do that in my
sleep your jump shot ain't jumping no
more like you ain't hitting that in the
gym no more like people ain't showing up
for your content so you try to spin it
off and try to fix it you're a spin
Thrift that gave you more money than you
was worth you didn't put that in the
background for your employees they come
to find out that these dudes the way you
did your employees I can't even feel sad
for you at this moment right now because
how you did your employees you spend the
money that was made for them you took
back their shares you cut them off with
a month with with a day left on their
insurance so they didn't have insurance
for the whole month they had it for one
day karma is a [__] like it's really
messed up and you you would want to feel
sad for them but after going through
this whole document after reading this
whole joint you got rid of everybody
that made it a home it was soulless now
you got nobody to defend you but your
financials and you you're lacking there
you try to do a last ditch effort on
Steam and try to do some little package
over there to get some bread they
rebuffed that that ain't work do you
right back so you ain't as cute as you
thought you was you ain't in your 20s no
more you ain't hot and smooth no more
now you pushing 40 you you you seeing
your mortality and that dude saw you
right there like
yeah now about that
rent you about to do something strange
for some change like it's about to
happen and it's over for you so now what
you GNA do like really they're gonna get
absorbed this is what the the re the
reality of the fact is final shape is is
good it's a good name because this is
your final
shape you out of shape you look at Like
Larry Holmes flabby as
[__] like Larry
Holmes and and it's at the point now
where it's over for you so now you're
looking over at Marathon like is that
gonna help is that gonna bring somebody
back but you tained your pool it was a
poison pill all money ain't good and you
you mess with the right person at the
wrong time and shout out to
Jim Jim why CA y y'all thought Jim
purchased them overpaid for
them no what Jim did was made you fall
for the bag because he know you like
money and you didn't read the contract
right so you was looking at the check
yeah signing them
zeros yeah baby we yo yeah yeah I'm
definitely going to Gucci after this for
sure R Chris no yeah we go rof Chris I
have to I have to I have to take back
something that I said from a like over a
year ago when the purchase went like it
been a year right yeah full year since
the announcement that they purchased
them and I was like you know I was like
yeah good for Sony they they purchased
these guys why not I'm like but um I was
saying Bungie got the better deal at the
time I was like oh they're walking away
with money and their freedom like I'm
like it's a win for them but yeah the
fine print was there that none of none
of us got to read Because clearly Bungie
didn't read it either right and now uh
basically Sony set them up to fail
because now that makes them able to just
snatch them up and completely own them
and have complete control over them now
it's it's it's crazy to see like Sony
was like they they set it all up they
set them up from the beginning like I
was like this is like like then this is
why they are a billion doll
Corporation they're not [__] stupid
you know so uh I'm saying sorry Bungie
not sorry you know like uh I was ring
for you but uh damn you should have had
some lawyers look at that [__] yeah
that's what it seemed like I feel like
lawyers did look at it here's the thing
I believe that Bungie really felt like
the community would never turn on them
they could continue putting out whatever
they want to and because they had such a
gra a grab a grasp on all the content
creators that make Destiny content their
fan base would just go with them uh but
it does look like those content creators
have turned against PlayStation and or
not PlayStation but B Bungie and I think
that's what you're seeing right now
you're seeing because the content
creators aren't playing as much anymore
because the Contra creators are making
videoos speaking out because I follow a
bunch of them and here recently they
have been very vocal and they're not
like that all the time you can ask Keem
they're very vocal about what's going on
right now with PlayStation and because
they are you're seeing their fan base
well if if you know if if AST cross
playing something else let me try
something else people don't realize how
much the the influencer content creator
streamer uh space keep people in these
games as a service this game is somehow
nominated for an award at the game of
what best community support none the I
I'm like
what they just let go
area I was like you gotta be
joking someone pulling one on me right
now hey I have a question um so if
PlayStation takes over Bungie right um
what are they going to do with Bungie
because we hear that they acquired them
for their expertise they acquired them
um for the bung I'm sorry the destiny IP
like what are they going to do with bung
because they don't know how to run a
studio that that that's the games as a
service Studio what are they going to do
let yeah I think my personal opinion is
they here's what I think happened I
think they didn't think this day would
ever happen where people push back they
need to to maintain that money so where
they're like okay they you know they got
all the higher ends because apparently
they asked them would uh did the higher
ups talk about doing a a cut of their
money like cut their bonuses and their
salary to keep people on and apparently
the person told IGN said they're not
we're not that kind of company
so I think the higher ups all came
together and said we don't want Sony to
take us over we want no hostile takeover
situation you know we got a contract in
play we just we need to bring an income
and they're like right
now who do we need to maintain making
marathon and Destiny and they're like we
need these people okay who's essential
who's actually working on the game who's
working on the social aspect who's
working yeah they and they're like we
need these people these are the core
people developing the game okay what are
these people doing there are social
aspect they go they they communicate
with the uh with the players they
communicate with influencers uh you know
we have these people over here in
security you know they're M they're
making sure that they is a safe playing
environment in our game and then
Bungie's like okay we don't need none of
them do they do they work on the game do
they develop no get rid of them all of
them and I feel like they they took
those they clean you think they cleaned
house like 343 did kind of situation
it's not about cleaning house I do think
eventually they will bring some of these
people back on I just think right now
they're trying to do whatever they can
to get them into that gray so Sony
doesn't take them
but see see but I'm reading something
and they said that you know like the
board has half PlayStation half bungee
people but bunge CEO Pete Parsons he's
the guy you know um if there's a some
some type of I don't know tie or
whatever he's the one that has the final
say but that that is how things normally
go if they don't meet expectations they
don't vote Sony just takes over okay
well but this is this is financial uh
fiscal periods so I think they missed
their um Financial fiscal that's when uh
it came out what they said but you you
on to something addict because they did
say that we have all the people here we
kept the correct people so that means
you got rid of the soul but you kept the
body and now people are talking about
like it's it's it's it's terrible to
work there Soul crushing they don't know
what's going to happen next and that
level of environment is just going to
Fester into turn into something bad I
see them when they when Sony does take
over they're going to do what they
wanted uh Sony I mean um Bungie to do
initially run the games of service right
I don't think Marathon comes out I think
marathons get puts on the Shelf I the
final shape fails Marathon gets put on
the shelf and I think they allow them to
work on all their games of service and
put them in the dir the salt mines to
get the busy and I think that's gonna
happen this is not good that's not good
cuz that's one too many multiplayer
games that's one too many multiplayer
games Sony has not gone off the ground
again ABS that would be that that's like
that's not good like I mean like this is
insane they can't get a single
multiplayer game off the ground how it's
gonna go I think they're going because
the reason they don't need no more
Community people is because final shape
is it for Destiny I don't think they
really have whole obviously they'll have
a skeleton crew making like the episode
stuff but I think in terms of like big
expansive content they're done with that
for the foreseeable future that's why
they haven't hired people to take over
the marathon stuff so I think I think
that's if they get over the hump they're
gonna hire the new people to take over
the marathon stuff because they still
kept some Community managers on Destiny
they just got rid of a few of them and I
think what's going up happening is
they're gonna put all these all these
eggs in in the marathon basket and I
think it's not going to perform well me
personally I don't think it's going to
do well but the but but out of the
unfortunate part they already saying
that there's potential that they can lay
off some more people yeah because they
their number one priority is to maintain
their independence and don't get it
twisted they will they will get rid of
everyone that they had that they
absolutely and they'll probably start
getting rid of like for instance the the
the composer the music dude that they
got rid of he's been there with them for
years he made too much money we don't
care he got to go because we need that
money in the next financial period damn
yeah damn it's crazy that's I I feel
like their goal is just to get just to
get to the point where Sony can't come
in there W with with with in squid squid
games they ass squid games they ass it's
like like you have to fight for your
jobs fight is crazy man they do that
because here's the thing Bungie usually
is pretty like family orientated like
they they've always been decently to to
their people I don't think Bungie truly
wanted to let all these people go I
think Bungie's in straight up survival
mode like they don't they signed a deal
because they thought that was the only
option they had and now their CES are
down because they've been because I feel
like they're okay what we'll do is we'll
over monetize everything and the Budgy
people ain't gonna say [__] they gonna
buy it it's wild it's like because like
Destiny is all they have like you didn't
get Bungie along with Halo then we'd be
talking but you got bungy with Destiny
and let's be real like Destiny has
always been a very midf franchise it
somehow has a lot of players somehow
does but but not in the beginning in the
beginning of a t it was it was yeah no
yeah yeah no it was a rough rough rough
launch both Twi twice it had a rough
launch
twice and and honestly like they don't
have much reputation to go on in this
one game marathon is not going I don't
think it's it's gonna be what appeals to
console guys yeah I think that they put
too much here's my thing you should the
reason I stopped playing Destiny is
because I could tell they're they their
heart isn't in Destiny anymore stuff
that Bungie the destiny players been
asked for like dedicated servers why
does ma why does marathon have that but
not Destiny so like I saw that and was
like they're clearly on another ship
this ship is sinking they just don't
want it's like the Titanic when they
were sick and they want to tell nobody
they're like no we good they had the
people planing to buy land get the wife
and children out of here yeah yeah so so
and then I think what will end up
happening is they'll get to a point
where they okay
Sony Sony is at the point where they
can't you know they they'll have this
conversation okay what what do we do and
they're okay what we need to do is we
need to support Marathon I don't know
how long Sony will support Marathon if
it's not successful out the game two
weeks so the same way they supported the
port let's say they do it for six months
I'm gonna give them the upper end of it
so they support it for six months if
it's not a hit out the gate because if
so if if Bungie was still independent
and they support Destiny like they
should have done because what it is they
took all their talent on the marathon
and they left Destiny with the Skeleton
Crew essentially and it blows my mind
how you take everyone out of the the
title you making your money from to
build another ship and then wonder why
your ship is taken in water because all
the engineers are in the other ship like
it is what it is I mean honestly like uh
when it comes to bunge Destiny 3 is like
their best shot at anything because
seeo what end up happening is Marathon
if it's not successful if it's
successful they'll be fine I just don't
think it's going to hit the way they
think that's just my opinion I think
said they ain't gonna make it well I
he's 98% right a lot of a lot of people
really a lot of people really like
Destiny so I think Sony will try to
support Marathon for a certain amount of
time and if if it doesn't do the way
they will they'll eventually plug it and
this is where I don't know what will
happen like they did the PlayStation for
part of
me won't shut down Bungie unless they
unless they flop Destiny 3 cuz I think
even if Marathon fails if final shape is
okay but it doesn't hit I do think at
the end of that shutting Marathon down
they're like we paid 2.5 billion you
gonna be working he's like go back no
that's 3.6 man no 3.6 I want you to go
and build Destiny 3 and then if they
fail Destiny 3 that's when Bungie will
be dissolved entirely yeah okay ad
that's nice I okay it's they don't got
that much longer right so listen that
ain't G to happen listen
I don't think Marathon comes out I think
they missed this fiscal period because I
think the final shape don't work out I
think the final shape is the final shape
and it's not g to go well nobody's gonna
come back it's gonna fall flat they're
gonna take over and when they take over
that new dude Hadi hu who's in place
right now he gonna say listen here what
are they good at they good at this we
have six games of service put them on
that let's see if they can make that
stuff successful because obviously
they're not good with what they had I
guess to me I do feel like they will
give a des here's the thing they they
bought that much they spent that much
money on Destiny I think they they will
have more and that that could be the
moment they bought them they're like oh
we're working on this oh that's cute I
need you on Destiny 3 they could be
working on it now for all I know oh this
marathon thing looks okay Destiny 3 I
need the majority you on Destiny 3 so I
we'll see they put them on a new
Socom yeah I feel you but here's the
thing I think that you are right they
probably wouldn't dissolve Bungie they
would just they would be you everyone's
[__]
now they turn you out S I think I think
I think uh Sony's gonna play it safe and
milk them for another Destiny that's
just really what they that's what I
think but because because like Bungie
like I said Bungie doesn't really have
impressive output outside of the Halo
games they had worked on but that was
like with like a previous team really it
wasn't like the whole like it's the
bungee of today is like vastly different
from the bungee we had in 2000 I could
see like I could see Destiny 3 failing
and then the the Finish him screen shows
up for the Mortal Kombat here's the
thing I don't think Destiny 3 would fail
player countwise but it would probably
the thing is I will disagree with you
I'll push back a little bit the destiny
Community because I'm really intertwined
in that Community they are not happy
right now at all and a l I know they're
not yeah people that will really a lot
of them have already left and people
there fortnite me and turtles me and
King play me and King play Destiny for
like nine years
really no longer play that wow I I was
playing with her when she was young PA I
tell you what why you you why don't you
gentlemen play Halo infinite with me
instead firefight now how about you get
yourself inside some fortnite let's do
that oh my God you're such a you're such
a boomer yes yes thank you I appreciate
it old man old man playing fortnite yes
that's right that's right and I mute the
kids that jump
in on his Crocs has ice cream in place
oh hold the hold the
CR I got the Crocs on right now
baby but that's pretty much all I got
like when it comes to the Bungie thing
look I
know Bungie Bungie made this still
PlayStation bought them for 3.6 billion
I think that's what king said yeah if
bung's not producing Sony does have
every right to step in like let's be
real it's their money they spent it is
not it's not they fault that Bungie sign
a deal like that so it's just like you
know I they set them up of course it's
not their
put a banana in the tailpipe PA I don't
know
how but if if they were giving retention
money and they didn't give it to the
people because it seems like some of the
people they got rid of they
intentionally got rid of them to not
give them that retention money see
that's what it seemed like that's
terrible though but see that ret see if
you if you keep some of the retention
money that's money that's going to keep
you afloat to go over that threshold
they need I see
that's numbers talk I don't like numbers
talk yeah but unfortunately the whole
world because you're not a PlayStation
fan so you know because PlayStation
dudes they love
numbers they love it they love they love
they love numbers but they don't like do
they don't know math but they love
numbers they love numbers they they like
the shapes of them they like yeah how
many zeros is it more yes I like
numbers get a be there
your dirt I like numbers
b b
[Laughter]
b actually I heard some numbers did did
you guys see there was a clip floating
around that uh some PlayStation Fanboy
said that Sony is going to make that
$3.6 billion doll back in 11 days did
you see that one yeah yeah yeah did you
see it okay yeah they love numbers right
yeah yeah yeah yeah they can't count
count as seven out of 10 for the
PlayStation showcase though that was a
no no that's a whole three bro that's a
whole three man hold that seven was a
seven out of 10 for Jay du what you
talking about n Jay dub know that was a
whole three bro you saw his face too he
was sitting there like I know I was
looking at his face for like 15 hours
editing he looked like Kan West bro
there's I wanted to edit you I wanted to
edit that that him on like the sad
Grandpa eating the cheeseburger by
himself I was
just I couldn't help it but he looks so
he looks so disappointed so sad so went
down and then he's just like it's a sing
out of 10 I'm like what yo the best part
about that was I told him if because we
have this pregame warmup before the show
I was roasting before the show before
the show started I said this is going to
be your worst show ever and he like he
like nah I said I got it him said I'm
never wrong I smell it y'all going
down he was
right all
right let's get these super chats and
head out out of here you guys are crazy
we got we got a find out super chat from
Adidas 20 Awards and tears tomorrow we
got a member chat from Adidas said
what's up y'all clap for Uncle
Phil
Adidas your your statue is going to go
out on Friday I just uh printed up the
label we got a $5 Super Chat from
Spartan 661 I thought having Henry Royal
uh R rylands was awesome in Def Jam
being the trainer in the games maybe
they can get other musicians that rap in
new games yeah yeah yeah man NBA young
boy little dirt let's go yeah on that
they started doing like instead of like
just like death jab they like
do like a like a Death Jam versus NBA or
something like that well I want the I
want the old rappers too I want the dead
rappers too I I I wanna I want I want
King vaugh I want Tupac I want b i all
of them King King you were a Genesis guy
growing up yeah I have everything no I
was I was a turbo Graphics dude though
you was a turbo Graphics dude you the
first person I ever heard say that yeah
yeah no I was I was a Genesis kid I was
a Genesis guy
man when I saw like you I saw you liking
a post on um the oh yeah you're talking
about the the the land Walker yeah land
Walker I was like wow I remember that
gotta gotta find out super chat from
Adidas Microsoft CEO have Sony customers
feeling some type of waying I I see what
you did to D
an splid house I us
love gqv what's up clown Sony took
Bungie on a first date and Bungie went
to third base and now they can't get
back
home
BR interesting situation with them I
wonder where it's gonna go they then
abusive
marriage that's I Tina right there baby
man all I want is my name all I want is
my name
Craig e the damn cake out of
man you gonna do that show
anime oh I hopo be beating
me classic stuff right there all right
so go ahead and end this podcast first I
want to thank forga and King for showing
up man no it was it was it was it was my
pleasure this is this is great this is
hilarious uh you know it's I I'm just
waiting to like talk about the game
awards when I get the chance to because
it's what when is it again it's tomorrow
tomorrow at 7 Eastern
Xbox Awards 7 Eastern a.m p.m. p.m. he
you on uh now you on the west coast
right yeah yeah I'm on Pacific Pacific
Northwest so like right now it's 4 4:30
p.m oh that's right it's s over here so
it would be 4 pm for me is when it would
when it would start I guess yeah okay so
I I mean I'll be I'll be streaming that
so if anybody wants to know where they
can find me tomorrow if they want to see
it that's where you can see me doing it
or you can watch these guys do it you
said see you doing it pause
pause honestly you're gonna want to
watch these guys do it instead because
King's gonna
probably be there I'm not gonna be there
oh you're not gonna be there oh then no
then come watch it with me what are you
talking
about oh I got somebody going in my
place they' be good they' be good no no
no no they ain't no uh they ain't no La
night you know La night
yeah let's let's let's let's keep this
going dirt man what's going on dirt
nothing much man yeah um I'm looking
forward to tomorrow um hopefully as spot
show some exciting stuff because we last
they ain't show nothing and was those
those guys out there losing their damn
mind you say what they took notes oh
you're gonna like what's happening all
right okay okay bro take you but um so
yeah man um check out uh so my boy Sean
is streaming it tomorrow I'm going to
join his stream because I couldn't do it
this year cuz I thought I had to do
something tomorrow but now I don't but
it's all good I know y'all don't give a
damn so yeah
man I how how did you know because I
don't even give a damn okay so yeah man
great show had a lot of fun y'all yeah
oh thank you thank you so King King
what's going on with you man
well you know Xbox front line dropping a
video every day King don't plate putting
in that work got a video right now yeah
for sure for sure for sure for
sure upload Ro lately he's like I told I
told people when I play I play hard man
I play for keeps I ain't I'm calling
show Fridays uh 6:30 pm. Eastern
Standard Time and listen you don't got
to pay to call in all you got to do is
just know how to follow the rules go in
Discord call in have a conversation if
any of you ponies did not like anything
that I said please call in on Friday and
let me know what I said that hurt your
feelings please all right so I can watch
y so call in with your cats in your
portal and talk to me I expect it it's
gonna it's gonna be jdub calling but
he's in the call trying to do a
different voice he's hey King B
me what
you if you want you can uh drop your
Twitter in the chat me yeah he said me
little old me me um it's uh well I I'm
not actually signed in onto this browser
but uh it's it's thck boy but it's just
the mie plug it in for the chat she's
here Mixie that's what's up hey be be a
deer and make the sandwiches too while
you're at it thanks I got a I got a
video dropping in a second it'll drop at
8 o'clock y'all gonna get that work I
told you I'm going keep that boot on
your neck this whole generation hash no
PlayStation 6 you're done
son the hold back he's like I'm in it to
win what I'mma stand over Kong when he's
dead you guys are ridiculous all right
but appreciate for coming through man
I'm G send you guys over there to fame
definitely go on there and hit that like
button man I'm sure he's he he going to
be loose today too man I think you guys
are going to enjoy it uh appreciate for
coming through we out of here peace
byebye
blessings
ah excellent